so i would like to begin by thanking the
organizers at labrus for the opportunity
to present some of the work that we've
been doing in my lab here at
microbiology virtually so to begin my
name is marjorie lawrence
i am an assistant professor in the
internal medicine department in the
section of infectious diseases at yale
university
and today i will tell you about my work
with cmtk2 and the title of my talk is
cmtk2 restricts the replication of
multiple slave viruses
so the primary goal of my research
program is to understand how voice
responses to viruses prevent or enhance
disease
one approach to accomplishing this is by
understanding how interference
stimulated genes such as cmpt2 which i
will tell you about today function and
coordinates with cellular networks
during viral infections
hence our overarching goal
in the lab to characterize cmtk2 and
define the molecular mechanisms by which
cmt2
inhibits virus replication
to identify and characterize those
factors that interact with cnp2 and
either enhance or decrease its function
there is great interest in targeting
interference simulated genes for
developing new antivirus therapies
rather than targeting viral proteins in
order to minimize emergence of antiviral
drug resistance
targeting an isg like cmtk2 may be an
effective strategy in the development of
normal antiviral therapies
upon infection sensing of viral nucleic
acids
by the cytosolic
pattern recognition receptors such as
regai and mda5 leads to the activation
of downstream signaling factors
culminating in the activation of irs 3
and irf7 which binds to the interferon
data promoter and induces expression
interferon is secreted and signals in an
autocrine are paraphrased manner by
binding to its receptor
upon interferon binding to the type 1
interferon receptor
this leads to the activation of the
jacksep signaling pathway resulting in
the formation of the heterotrimeric
complex the interference simulated gene
factor-free complex which translocates
into the nuclear and binds to the
interference stimulated response
elements in the promoter region of
interference simulated genes such as
cmt2 which drives the transcription and
expression of proteins leading to an
antiviral state
to
um
to prevent viral verification and
dissemination
now pathos success successful pathogenic
viruses such as flashy viruses and the
physical v2 for instance have
these viral antagonists that
affect and
inhibit these systems so for example
dysplasia viruses like lung heart virus
japanese encephalitis is viral
west nile virus dengue virus zika virus
have been shown from work that we did
with that i did as a great student that
these viruses inhibit
the interferon signaling pathway and
this has good work that has been done
from by myself
and also
with the staff for v2
labs have shown that sas 42 inhibits the
production of interference signaling as
well as the interferon and signaling
pathways
so cmck2
in human is formed
adjacent to uninverted with respect to
rs-82 the isg that encodes for the
antiviral protein
vibrant
these are this genomic organization is
present in all vertebrates and in lower
organisms cmtk2 and rs82 are filled
cmpk2 and viperine are caution priced
upon induction of interferon signaling
cmpk2 and course for the interferon
stimulated protein cyclist monophosphate
dynamics so it's a 449 amino acid
protein
with a
m different mitochondria localization
sequence at the end terminal which is
the first 22 amino acids there is an
n-terminal domain and a c-terminal
domain
now the mitochondrial localization
sequence
transport causes some cmtk2 to localize
to the mitochondria primarily
now the first half of the protein the
n-terminal domain has no known homology
to any other protein and the biological
function is unknown
the c-terminal domain is conserved
across species and it's responsible for
the kinase activity
cmtk2 was originally
reported in 2008
in a publication in jvc
to phosphorylate scientific
monophosphate and uridine monophosphate
to their respective diphosphates using
atp as uh as a
donor however
a recent report in 2018 from stephen
alamos group over at albert einstein
published in nature showed that
cmpk2 principally operates on scientific
in different phase uridine diphosphate
to form the triphosphorylative
form um cited in triphosphate and
uridine triphosphate respectively
now acidity is then used as the
substrate for vibranium right and it's
vibrating then using ctp to make dbhttp
ddhptp then gets incorporated into
nation rna and acts as a chain
terminator for rna dependent polymerases
or slavic viruses
after this paper was published in 2018
there was a paper from karen's group in
20 in in nature that showed that cmpk2
is placer rolling information by
activating the
inflammatory
after this publication there was a story
in science advances that showed that
cmtk2 plays a role in restricting hiv
reputation but the mechanism by which
pmpk2 inhibit hiv was not elucidated in
that study
afterwards at that time we started this
project where we examined whether tmtk2
plays a role in inhibiting viral
replication and at the time we began
that story we used a zika virus a flashy
virus as our model
so zika virus is an rna virus in the
fleshy virus genus belonging to the
slave israeli family it's closely
related to dengue and west nile virus
and yellow fever virus
zika virus was actually first isolated
in 1947
and remained in relative obscurity for
about 70 years or so until 2015 when it
was transmitted
to when it was um transmitted in brazil
introduced to brazil in 2016 from the
um
in 2015.
now we know that zika virus is
transmitted in this human to mosquito
human transmission cycle however there
is evidence that shows that zika virus
can be transmitted from the mortar to
the theta and there are also
reports of sexual transmission
one in five people who become infected
become ear from zika virus with symptoms
of a rash fever and conjunctivitis and
symptoms last anywhere from two to seven
days
there are no treatments
and treatment is supportive and there
are no vaccines
to assess the biological effects of
cmtk2 in controlling zika virus
infection we generated a specificity
to give the temperament we can examine
though
the
wearing cmtk2 can be regulated in a time
and dose-dependent manner
so very briefly full-length cmtk2 was
cloned into an antivirus response vector
system controlled by a tetracycline
response element
zero cells were transduced with this
lengthy virus encoded in either cmp
or an empty vector for our control
and the reason we use the zero cells is
because zero cells has a genetic defect
in producing interferon however the
cells do respond to exogenous
interferons
so this gives us the advantage of one
being able to turn on the isg of
insurance in our case tmp2 without
turning on other interference stability
genes and so being able to examine the
effects on viral replication by
regulating expression of the protein of
injury
so the first thing we did after we
made the cell
we examined whether the cmpk2 twist
express upon treatment with doctor
cycling and here in sunil
you can see the expression of pmpk2
in panel b we examine biconfocal
microscopy the subcellular localization
of cmtk2 as i said at the beginning
cmtk2 has a mitochondria localization
sequence that
that localizes it to primarily the
mitochondria and what you see in panel b
in cell structures doxycycline is the
expression of cmpk2
in the second panel the lower panel
and in the third panel we have the
microtracker which is the marker for the
mitochondria and what we see is
co-localization
of cmtk2 with the miter tracker
confirming that cmtk2 is primarily
localized to the mitochondria
next we examine the effect of cm2 on
zika virus replication
we use the cells and we either mock
treated or treated with doctor cycling
for 24 hours so we allowed
tmp2 to the express as i showed in panel
a
then 24 hours for
treatment with doxycycline the cells
were infected with zika virus with a
multiplicity of infection of one from
now on i will just say moi so an moi of
one
24 hours post infection that we have is
the supernatant and we examine by and we
examine for um viral reputation some
quantification of the virus by plaque
assay
and what we observe
is that in cells strictly in cells
treated with doctors and cream and
expressing cmtk2 that we have a box a
force which is a log difference of zika
virus replication so in comparison to
cells expressed in comparison to cells
not not expressing cmt
so that
results
for short off that cmtk tool has an
effect on zika virus replication
next to complement our cmpt inducible
cell system we used a crispr casting
approach to deplete cmtk2 cells
cmtk2 in human protein fibroblast cells
so very briefly a lentivirus vector was
used to deliver either a non-targeting
guide rna which is our control or a
guide rna to
targeting cmtk2
we then confirmed that tmpk2 was not
sold in the cell and then we used a
lengthy crispr vector to deliver a guide
rna against cas9 and that was done in
order to guard against off targeting
effects
we then validated that our gene of
interest was removed by internal air
by qpcr and here you see a lockdown of
the mrna right the the message and
by western blossom
and here we see in wild side cells and
the non-targeted human phosphine fibrous
blood cells
treated with interferon you have
upregulation again of isgs
you see expression of the protein cmtk2
and here viprine is just a control you
see expression of vibrance and in the
cmpk2 knuckle cell you see you don't see
cmpk2
next we use this cell
to evaporate effects of some zika virus
replication
so again we use the cells to infect them
we speak a virus as an moi of one six
hours fourth
infection
we treated the cells with
blood treated or treated with interferon
this will allow the cells to
um interferon will bind its receptor
right and there will be pop regulation
of all these isgs when you treat it
interference
16 hours later
we have a stick with supernatant for
virus quantification by black acid and
what we observe
is that
in cells the non-targeted cells the
empty cells as well as the cnp the local
cells
when the cells are not treated with
interferons you have similar
virus anxieties
however as expected in the non-targeted
cells interferon reduce the replication
of zika virus in the cells again because
when you treat the cells with
interference you have an upregulation of
all these isgs and you have a reduction
in viral replication
however in the cmt to local cells there
was no difference in replication between
the non-interferon
treatment versus the interfering
treatment which confirms that because
that cmtk2 plays a role in zika virus
replication
given the similarities in the molecular
biology of the flavor viruses we
examined with whether cmtk2 plays a role
in the replication of other crazy
viruses
so to do that
we
use our doctor cycling inducible cell
system
and we
would mock trees or through toxicity
24 hours for treatment again we would
infect with our virus of injuries in
this case we're going to examine a few
medically relevant
physioviruses
and then we would
24 hours later we would collect the
supernatants for analysis by flakkazi
now in this story that i will show you
also we will also have
viruses expressed in fluorescent
proteins and in the studies when we have
viruses expressing fluorescent proteins
we will harvest the cells and we will do
flow cytometry for analysis
so once we saw is that
cmpk2 inhibits
zika virus dengue virus verification
cmck2 inhibits pungent virus reputation
another flavor virus
cmtk2 inhibited yellow fever virus
another flavor virus so our results so
far shows us that
cmtk2 inhibits multiple fleshy viruses
given the results that cmpk2
inhibits hiv reputation as i said that
was published sometime in 2018 and our
results we
from four different flavor viruses we
ask whether cmtk2 may affect the
reputation of other virus families other
virus families including
corrupt the piranhas everyday from the
or for mixed overeating family
and again we use our doctor cycling
inducible system for viruses
containing a fluorescence and protein we
will use facts analysis for um for
analysis whereas if the virus
does not express a fluorescent protein
we will use black acid
and what i'm going to show you here
is that we examined tmpk2 effect on a
virus of the coroner's
sexual franchise virus which is an avian
virus and what we see by plaque analysis
analysis is no different no effect on
idv replication
next we examined
whether cmtk2 affected sas 42 the
ethiologic agent of the current progress
19
and we saw no difference by plaque assay
next
we examine whether team kits will affect
other
relevant viruses so for example we
discuss
influenza virus here we have we are
using an influenza virus expressing a
fluorescent protein this is pre-gfc
and
he has deposited itself himself
expressly and cmtk2 are not expressing
cnp2 we cause similar results with the
new path of disease virus which belongs
to the para mix of irrita family
similar results with vestibulosomatic
virus belonging to the rhabdos irradiate
family
and we examined a dna virus with the
simplex virus belonging to the herpes
v-relay family and we saw no effects of
the implicator on these viruses
so
given the effective antiviral activity
of cmtk2 against multiple splashy
viruses including dengue
zika and yellow fever
cmt2 actually would make an attractive
target for the development of muscle
antiviral therapy while dissecting the
mechanism by the cmpk to inhibit
dyslexia viruses may hear the new
strategies for translating the antiviral
activity of cmpk2 into a clinically
useful
compound
so to look to towards the the mechanism
of action we first go towards the
the domain of tmpk2 and what are the
requirements for these different domains
so to begin we first asked the question
does the mitochondrial localization of
cmck2 is that required for its antiviral
function
so again as i've shown you before that
cmpk2 has a mitochondrial localization
sequence that takes it into the
mitochondria you can see that in panel a
the lower part of panel air when treated
with doxycycline
so for our studies we generated
we generated this expression plasmid
either expressing an empty vector as a
control our wild side
tmp keto infernal b
or a variant lacking the first 22 amino
acids so one would express that these
variants would lack the ability to
localize to the mitochondria
first thing we did we examined for
protein expression by immunoblot
analysis and observed that both the
wireside and the delta mls which lacked
those space-22 amino acids were
expressed to similar levels
next we examined the subcellular
localization by controlling microscopy
and we observe that the wild type this
is infinitely v or first part of the
panel of these the wild side localizes
with the miter tracker which is the
marker for the mitochondria however the
delta mls which lacks the
the
22 amino acids required to take it into
the mitochondria remain cytosolic as
expressive
so next we examine the effects of this
mutant protein
on zika virus replication so to do that
we used
293 cells and we transfected them with
these expression vectors
24 hours post transfection we infected
the cells with zika virus as an moi of
one and 24 hours fourth infection we
have achieved the supination for
quantification by plaque assay
and what we observe
is that
the wire size cmtk2 inhibits zika virus
replication which confirms what we saw
with our inducible system in the zero
cell however the cmck2 variant lacking
the first 22 amino acids which is no
longer
no longer
localized to the mitochondria lacks this
ability to inhibit zika virus
replication
to ensure that this is not an effect of
expression we use immunogloss analysis
to look at the expression of these
proteins and we saw similar levels in
spaniel b of the wild side and the
mutant
we also examined the
envelope protein which is one of the
structural proteins of zika virus by
and saw that there was a decrease in the
enzyme protein in the wildlife cells as
expected as
zika virus it means the reputation of
cmpk2 inhibits the reputation of sickle
virus
so what this tells us is that the
mitochondrial localization of cmtk2 is
required for its antiviral function
next we examine the contribution of each
of these domains as i said at the
beginning you have the mitochondrial
localization sequence
and you have that
which is the arrival between species and
you have the c-terminal domain which is
well-confident and the c terminal domain
is responsible for the kinase activity
and
we generated
these oxidizedly inducible cells
expressing these mutant proteins for our
studies so we have the white side
protein the dilution museum which i've
shown you before
would not inhibit
zika virus replication we made a
catalytically inactive
cmtk2
protein
i'm using proteins
and we
newtons expressed in the first half of
the the protein so an n terminal domain
with and without the mitochondria
localization sequence and we have the c
terminal domain with and without the
mitochondria localization sequence
so we first examine the expression of
these
newton proteins by immunoblock analysis
and what we observe in phenylb is that
the mutants expressing only the system
in our domain they are very poorly
expressed and moving forward in our
experiments we did not use the
systeminal domain
next
we examine the subcellular localization
of this mutant protein and as expected
the
proteins
containing the mitochondria localization
sequence for example the wild side the
catalytically enacted d320a as well as
the n-terminal domain 1-2-1 they are all
localized primarily in the mitochondria
however the mutants lack in the
mitochondria localization sequence
are primarily cycle solid like xerox mls
and the newton's 23-201
then we examine the effects of these
mutants on zika virus replication and
what we observed is that in keeping with
what we've seen before that the wild
side reduces zika virus reputation
of unlike the delta mls which are
showing you before does not inhibit zika
virus certification now i'd like you to
go to
so we're in phaneuxy
and let's go to the last
um
to the last few baths so that is the one
to 201 to the 203201
and what we see with the oneplus 201 is
that this first half of the cmpt2
inhibits zika virus replication
which means that the c terminal domain
and the kinase activity is not required
for cmpk2 antiviral functions yeah in
the last um
part you see here that the 203 201 this
is the first half of cmpk2 lacking the
mitochondria localization sequence is in
is unable to inhibit data virus
replication again highlighting the
importance of the localization of them
between the mitochondria for this
antiviral function
now as i said the c terminal domain and
the kinase domain
is not required based on these um these
expertise this data and the
catalystically enacted cmpk2 where an
aspartic acid of course amino acid
position frequency was changed to an
aluminium yeah this catalytically in
acid cmpk2
is also able to inhibit zika virus
replication confirming that the kinase
activity of cmt2 is not required for its
antiviral function
so what i've shown you today
in conclusion is that cmtk2 inhibits the
reputation of multiple previous viruses
making it a very attractive candidate
for use as a as an antiviral
i've shown you that the mitochondrial
localization of cmtk2 is required for
its antiviral activity
and i've shown you that the n-terminal
domain of cmtk2 and not the terminal
domain not the kinase activity is
required for its antiviral function
now this brings us to some of the
more foreign experiments that we're
doing on more current questions that
we're asking
so cmt keto has its n-terminal domain
that is highly variable with no known
function and i just showed you that this
n-terminal domain
and the mitochondrial localization is
required for its antiviral function and
not the c terminal domain
and the kinase activity
i've shown you that
the recent reports a few months ago two
months ago also by lay at all that
showed that cmtk school in its dengue
virus reputation along with
um the report in 2018 that showed that
cmct2 impedes hiv reputation
makes it even more interesting and hence
why we're doing this current studies
right now trying to identify the
specific amino acid residues within the
n-terminal domain that is required for
this activity as i said we have no idea
what the first end terminal the first
half of the protein what the function is
so this would be a first step in trying
to to understand
what the
what's the implications of of those
results that we're seeing
some of the other things that we're
doing we're trying to figure out what
are the whole factors that interact with
cmck2 and enhance or
decrease its function we have already
used the biotin proximity labeling
approach to identify cellular proteins
that are proximal to cmt cable and we
are currently validating disease uses
for universitization assets general
studies and to try to
figure out what is the biological
relevance of the heat start results
something else we have to figure out is
what are the some of the effects of
cmck2 on cellular metabolism on
nucleotide biosynthesis
and interestingly what we're doing now
is trying to figure out where zika virus
develop adaptive mutations to antagonize
cmt2 function so at the beginning i
showed you last slide that platy viruses
have evolved to immediately force immune
responses to ensure their reputation and
survival
persistent expression of interference
simulated genes like cmct2
result in
selection pressure expressions and
subsequently viral forces pieces may
emerge that can overcome the host immune
response so far we have done serial
passaging of zika virus in cells
expressing empty cases we have isolated
virus from the systolic the supernatant
and i've seen this for sequencing and
currently we are
analyzing this data so we have many
interesting avenues that we are
following in four cmp and with that
i will end here and i would like to
thank
i would like to send joanna paula who is
a postdoctoral fellow who joined my
group last
last october and has really taken this
project and has really done tremendous
work with it so i am very grateful for
her help and joining my lab this early
on as i only started my lab last last
july actually so about a year ago
and jack
who has been working with joe also and
collaborating with us on this project so
i'm very grateful
and
many thanks also to jack for other
projects that we've collaborated on
which we did not talk about here today
maybe we'll come back next year and talk
a little bit more about some of these
three
i would like to find the chrysler lab
peter creswell my my mentor i did my
post doctoral studies with peace and
actually all this was we started this
work
with um
pete when i was uh
and he has been very supportive and um
i've learned so much from him and i
continue to learn about pharmacy
and patrick han who is a postdoc with
this who has done some studies with um
pmt so he's talking also to some of our
stories and i thought i did not show
today and other members of the lab
i would like to thank
juliet morrison and her lab for
collaborating with us on the stories
with dengue virus and team keto
and
the some of the labs here at dale has
been very general um helping me with
this with reagents errol secrets and his
lab
and errol is also my section chief in my
in my department so thanks for his
support craig weiling who helped us set
up all our
aquico and her lab a doll forecaster
sashay who i did my thesis to work with
and who continues to be very supportive
and listen urine in his lab
um who is more actually an assistant
professor
um environmental health and safety here
at yale who has been critical in helping
us setting up the fast forward to work
on some new projects that are actually
starting now
all the
um
cartoons were done with biorender and i
would like to stand for funding for the
yale center for clinical investigations
for their award for support and the
joanna is supported by the laboratory
very soon
the audience again thank you